hey and welcome to conan o'brien needs a
friend and i just heard gurley's phone
go off as we started and maybe if you
back it up girly we can hear that and
boost the sound and here it is
all right what is that what's going on
you're a professional you've been
podcasting since you were one of the
first people to invent a podcast that's
right you were doing this in the 1950s
that's why i get a certain amount of
latitude for my phone going off what was
the deal with your phone who was trying
to contact you sound detected on glenn
the friend's crib this is the nanny
going off in my daughter's nursery um i
don't understand well my daughter's name
is glenn and we we just call her glenn
the friend and so this is a notification
that there's sound in her nursery wait
you have a machine
that is listening to your daughter it's
not a machine it's a baby mom
what well i'm just i just find it creepy
it's very orwellian i love saying things
are orwellian because everyone overuses
it wow this tea is so orwellian
my daughter's not spouting like hot
button topics that need free speech
she's either crying and needs something
so we want to be alerted right but but
you're here at work
and your daughter is um at home yeah in
a crib so what can you do about this
situation why are you being alerted
because this thing's always on so when
i'm home i and i need to tend to her i
don't think to turn it off before i come
here because i'm just gonna have to turn
it on again also i like to i can check
in on it from here too and she might
just be gooing and giggling and it's
nice nice you know i should get one i'm
sorry no i don't think so i think
that we are
it's this whole helicopter parent thing
we're too involved and it starts right
now and this is a great example gourley
you're you've got a device in the crib
that's listening to every sound and then
you're right now 25 miles away
uh and you're getting an alert that
maybe she gurgled or burgled and you
can't do anything about it well i'm not
i'm not worried that she needs my help
my wife is there but sometimes i might
just want to check in and just get a
taste it's not you're right that's not
your right it is you don't even know
your kids names why should i
there's number one in number two i know
the first one was a girl and the second
one was a boy
so so but we said number one and number
two and i've got a busy life i've got a
podcast to do i've got self care and
maintenance i'm sorry i think your
priorities are different but you know
that's okay all right well listen i was
i think
a good father until i was asked to to
separate from children
but i i think i was a very good father
very attentive father but
i don't remember being
um you know at work like at rock or
center with a device that goes
your son just breathed a little bit
your son just exhaled didn't exist it
didn't exist
it wasn't that long ago we're only
talking 16 years
no but this is the new thing now so
parents now sona do you have a device
right now that tells you oh wait no you
have
a family
a massive family that takes care of your
children well no yeah you do i mean we
we have a lot of help from family but we
did have a monitor and then there's i
think not a day goes by where i'm like
we need a we need a new monitor cause
now we just like put them in their crib
and if they're not making sounds we just
leave them there but when you would
listen to the monitor didn't you just
hear armenian people shouting what i
mean seriously you have so so but he's
talking about if like you know the baby
needs you and is crying then you can't
hear them then you like go in there
because it's so much chaos over at
sona's house sometimes you have to admit
it is it i'm not gonna lie you've got
your you've got yeah you've got your
father okay you've got your mother
you've got tax parents yeah you've got
uncles and aunts and straws and rosie
and gross you know it's like all these
no i'm not
what is strozi and brosie what are their
names or are those relatives no no i'm
just saying when i go over there there's
so many people and by the way they are
lovely i i love your family and i want
to make that very clear and i've been to
armenia with you and i think i am very
in touch with the armenian people so you
think you can just say like strozie and
brazil actually and rosie are real
people who are there they are
they're her uncles and you know uncles
who's the uncle you have you had one
uncle that uh said that i was looked
like i was in good shape but i need to
lose ten pounds
he didn't say he yeah
i'm losing weight i feel like i need i'm
gaining weight and he's like ah you
could lose 10 pounds he did that was
rosie yeah and then brosie was like yeah
i think so too
and then they both said do you want some
flattened pomegranate that's been dried
on a rock and i said i think i'm pretty
good
that happened ah never forget it i never
ten years ago i never forget a put down
you never forget you told me you could
lose 10 pounds and guess what he's not
wrong yeah
bro
i got totally strozied and then on the
back side i got brosie yeah stro um
but uh no what i'm saying is sona
doesn't need a baby monitor because
she has twins she can barely get her
hands on those kids
because there's constantly people there
rosie and brosier are there but they're
you know i i understand what what matt's
saying though it's good to have a
monitor and watch your children and and
make sure that they don't need anything
there are times where i'm like i should
have a monitor and see if they need me
for something you know what now i feel i
do feel badly and i think you should
activate your phone there's a way to
activate it so it only buzzes if
it's glenn we can also
talk to her oh really yeah okay yeah
let's exploit yours
sure what's going on before we do that
no problem with that you said you felt
bad no no for a minute i felt bad that i
i made i don't want you to turn off of
course
oh are we listening right now let's
listen okay um this is incredible
awesome so invasive well we'll be able
to glenn glenn is how many months now
let's make a picture almost eight months
almost eight months old and she has a
microphone dangling over her crib
and you're 20 miles away in a podcast
let's see if we can get studio amanda to
come in here well you're calling amanda
right now well i'm gonna use the baby
monitor to see if we can get them to
come into the nursery hey uh marty it's
marty
uh can you bring glenn into the nursery
this is gonna freak her out i know it is
wait what's happening amanda
who's marty it's our nickname for each
other we call each other marty it's a
long story wait a minute her name's
amanda which is a beautiful name and
you're calling her marty well she
started calling me marty and
i didn't like it real creative revenge i
just started calling her marty okay yeah
amanda are you there marriage this is
are you there
i'm on the baby monitor
it'd be great if we just got a real
slice into his life where she was like
you
is
again
he doesn't know yet that we're listening
amanda
when are you going to be a real man come
on the baby monitor we're on the podcast
is the baby there i would kill the
baby's not in the crib oh my god the
baby's not in the crib i know but you
heard a sound in the crib
she must have gotten picked up and taken
out or said no one's listening to me
dad's got me on an app i am out of here
is that possible that's creepy there's a
black and white
video of an empty crib which i just find
chilling but you had baby monitors i
know that if we have eyes on here she'll
be like of course we had a baby monitor
yeah but we weren't listening to it when
we were 60 miles away right right that's
just that's the part i find weird and we
weren't connecting it to a podcast
because they were it was a relatively
unknown art form then uh-huh and i did
say art form i think i've elevated it oh
she's sitting in the nursery chair who
is i see you marty can you hear me i see
you
this is this i'll admit this is creepy
well first of all you're calling your
wife marty hi amanda i don't mean to
scare you name of an ernest borgnine
movie we're doing a podcast and we're
just checking in with you guys just
checking in i'm just going to keep
muttering while he babbles to his wife
whose name is not marty can you hear me
what a cute arrangement i'll call you
marty if you call me marty can you hear
me yeah oh my god oh you're on the
podcast right now yeah you're on the
podcast amanda or should i call you
marty
oh wait say that again
you're on the podcast amanda or should i
call you marty
oh my god is she okay did she just say
did she just say help help i'm married
to a monster
they're
they're worried you're you're taken
hostage right now
are you okay
say that again are you okay
do you okay
this seems like the worst way to talk to
someone yeah we're talking on a podcast
into an iphone that's connected to a
baby monitor she's also topless and
breastfeeding so we should oh for god's
sake
you can't see her well
how come
oh my god well i'm sorry i'm interested
in how nursing works
that is isn't there a creep isn't there
a sort of a panoramic
thing you can click on
hi i'm a known creep
they can't see anything but we'll let
you go sorry to disturb you this was a
horrible mistake yeah we're sorry um
amanda aka marty and um please go back
to
feeding your child
with your own body
oh my god
one body feeds another i'll see you soon
if i'm still allowed oh
god that was um what an invasion all
around yeah i regret that that was a
terrible idea of yours it was a great
disservice to my wife sitting there
breastfeeding she was just breastfeeding
on a podcast she just sent me a picture
of glenn's reaction to that whole thing
oh my god look at that reaction
that is a fantastic reaction put that up
online
wait they're doing what who's that [ __ ]
wait yeah and you know what she
unlatched to make that [ __ ] she did i
saw her that meant she gave up
sustenance to make it quite clear to us
that were a bunch of [ __ ]
i am a horrible horrible father and
husband wow at least now everything
matches
bad dad
bad friend
bad co-worker
we've got to move on uh that was
incredible and she is beautiful by the
way i will end on that thank you your
wife's beautiful your daughter's
beautiful i think i'm attractive too
if i'd get some work done all right just
give a compliment and just leave it
i can't it's gotta be about me
just say something a beautiful wife yeah
beautiful daughter and a beautiful
co-worker and then don't say anything
yeah okay just let it go the podcast is
named after me conor marion it's a
friend
it's actually named after like a a state
of being not really after you it's a
it's kind of like a sad state of being
is what it's named after okay soon it's
gonna be changed to conan gray needs a
friend
guy's beating me every day he's more
popular he was at the met gala okay i
went there once i was asked to leave but
i went